Trump just endorsed 11 folks nine of
them won okay and you know what that
means when it's 9 out of 11. that's
great that's Steph Curry type of free
throw shooting that you're doing
elections around the corner no matter
how much [ __ ] people talk and say the
guy's over with he's running 99 chance
and he's gonna be the nominee for the
right and there's a high likelihood he
wins because DeSantis is not running not
this time around the Santa is probably
going to wait till running for 2027 2028
then running this time I may be wrong
it's my speculation okay
um what what do you stand with what's
going to happen in 2024 with Trump
winning how how much different do you
think the climate's Gonna Be One do you
think he'll win too if he wins how
different of an America is 2024 versus
when he won in 2016. well I think that
um I more or less agree with your
assessment I think that if Donald Trump
wants it I don't think DeSantis is going
to challenge him in a primary you don't
think he could be a running mate uh
that's that's possible would he be a VP
pick I mean that that I could offer them
two outfits yeah probably not the best
for uh for Trump I I don't know about
that but I don't think he'll Run for the
nomination look I think you have a base
in the Republican Party a huge
percentage of the base genuinely
believes that Donald Trump is the
legitimate president yeah and that Joe
Biden wasn't legitimately elected that's
a huge percentage of the base in the
Republican Party the he has beloved
amongst the Republican base still I
think if that that nomination is his if
he wants it and then
I don't I really don't know if Joe Biden
ends up running for re-election but it's
either him or Kamala Harris either way
the weakest candidate that the Democrats
could possibly feel to be honest I don't
see how you have a Democrat president
after 2024 I mean what do they have to
run on they have inflation social media
dominance lockdown I mean it just people
it's like look we're the party who wants
to like kick you out of your job if you
don't get a vaccine that doesn't even
work
um we want to destroy your dollar and we
want to propagate propaganda as your
six-year-old with like sex education or
something like that these are not
popular positions and the truth is that
Donald Trump running man is going to
bring just a Hellstorm of media insanity
and it'll be I think hilarious and weird
but I the country is at a very different
place Donald Trump is older I mean I
know go we got used to Joe Biden being
so old and he's really like 15 years
older than his actual age
um but Donald Trump in what I've seen in
the clips of his rallies I think he's
just like
he doesn't quite have the magic to me
that he had in 2016. I think he's a
little out of touch with where his base
is a little out of touch with where the
country is I've seen him like bragging
about how he made the vaccines and the
people in his crowd are kind of like
well we're like not really that's not
really our thing
I haven't noticed that so I still think
he could win but I do think this is a
it's a different landscape and a
different Dynamic than than 2016. so I'm
interested to see how it all plays out
81 million people didn't vote for Joe
Biden they voted against Donald Trump
when you combine that with the fact that
as Dave was saying I mean Trump has been
booed a couple of times at his rallies
like I do think he's kind of like kind
of lost track of some of some of his
base and it's his base that he relies on
I think that if Donald Trump if Donald
Trump runs for the nomination it is
basically a certainty that he will get
the Republican nomination
I think that the only way that the that
Joe Biden Kamala Harris whoever it is
that is the Democrat candidate can try
to change the subject from the at that
point the last four years of them being
in office and the consequences of that
as well as bad policies that happen
under Trump that they supported like
stimulus spending and things like that
the only way they can change the subject
is to make it a litmus test on someone
that a good percentage of the country
hates like Donald Trump so I don't know
if Donald Trump is the best for the
Republican party to run now even bigger
as a Libertarian
you'll notice that none of us here tried
to seriously say that a Libertarian has
a shot in 2024 that is a problem
that's why I started yet no that's fair
that's fair that's why I started you are
the power is because we have to grow
from the Grassroots up to be able to
make it so that one day there is serious
contention for a Libertarian libertarian
candidate in 2024. not with a series
lightning strike Hail Mary passes that
all seem to work out but with an actual
feasible plan to be able to do that
there are two pieces I want to bring up
one is libertarian peace libertarian
party's goal in 2024 should be to get
electoral votes that's what it should be
there should be gold on that map what
that is whether that's Utah or chunk of
Nebraska whether that's a chunk of Maine
who splits up their stuff well that's
New Mexico whatever it is Wyoming there
should be a gold piece on that map
because that map is shown a bazillion
times and that map is what will get us
to be real so we have a real shot at
winning in 2028 so we must get some type
of electoral victory in 2024 as far as
Trump goes I'm not sure Trump is going
to run there is value in him being King
maker and I think he does like it he
might decide to be king maker
um if he runs I think he will absolutely
win the nomination without question I
think that's guaranteed but he Michael
you know what I like being the puppet
master I'm gonna sit back here and
endorse you with Norse you you guys go
he might I still think that's an option
for him to do but I think if he does run
he'll make it if the if the Republicans
run a DeSantis Gabbert ticket or
something like that someone DeSantis
cannot get left but someone like a
gabbard or someone like that whenever
the person who can get the left office
what's the second name you're saying
good Bart like yeah okay got it Chelsea
gabbard can draw the Left Right anyone
who to the left if the Republicans got a
DeSantis and someone can draw the left
they will easily sweep it
um the I think Trump will can still win
but the issue is will there be a culture
War issue that will pop up that year
like abortion is now if a culture War
issue pops up Republicans might lose in
2024. if not they're going to win the
issues only will they and the reason why
I say it is I know people in New York
state lots of them they are not
Democrats but I know some of them I know
are not Democrats they're Republicans
this bro we bait we the way thing popped
up they are angry they are mad they are
pissed off and it doesn't affect them at
all in New York state you are not
affected whatsoever by this and they are
angry so who's angry exactly a women
Republican women and Independent Women
are angry at this even though it does
not affect them at all they're so angry
so if there is a Ultra Warrior issue
that pops up then Republicans May
struggle pumpkins the other major
they'll be a manufactured culture
the other major X Factor is a hot War
some type of real hot war that develops
that changes everything good point two
years away you never know what's going
on if that happens we have to stay out
let them let them yeah I would I
certainly would like to yes and I think
he was more referring to either starting
or conflagrating
because presidents in Wartime tend to
get reelected and that that might be a a
this is an exception though this is a
very weird president and interesting
times yes very weird yeah it's also true
you know it's and it's people on both
sides are just kind of like what the
hell let's just everyone's like when I
was in military I would in boot camp I
don't know if you remember the wood
Countdown the days okay how many days do
I have left and you go there's there's
people people in their closets no one
sees they're counting down how many days
are left with the current Administration
to get somebody else to take over left
and right by the way it's not just like
it's only people on the right in the
middle so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]